nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
en novembre dernier en Chine des
milliers de jeunes ont manifesté contre
les confinements interminables les tests
PCR imposés et demandez davantage de
liberté le mouvement a été étouffé en
quelques jours mais la politique zéro
covid à la chinoise a été démantelée
desserrant les taux mis en place depuis
le début de l'épidémie avec nous en
duplex de Shanghai loup quizziella qui
va nous emmener à la découverte de cette
jeunesse rebelle chinoise loup quel a
été le point de départ de ces
manifestations
le déclencheur c'est le 24 novembre 2022
un incendie dans la ville de rouanschi
fait 10 morts dans un bâtiment en vertu
de la politique zéro covid cet immeuble
est alors confiné depuis plus de trois
mois comme l'intégralité de la province
du signe Djang à l'époque et vidéo à
l'appui des internautes chinois ont
alors blâmé le confinement de cette
immeuble en disant que c'était à cause
de cela que les pompiers n'avaient pas
pu sauver tous les habitants ça provoque
beaucoup de colère les jours suivants
dans plusieurs villes du pays des
veillées funéraires sont organisés en
hommage aux morts d'urucci et tellement
de monde s'y rassemblent que peu à peu
la foule se demandait la fin de la
politique zéro covid mais aussi plus de
liberté certains critiquent même si Jean
Ping vous l'avez dit le mouvement est
très vite réprimé mais le simple fait
que cette jeunesse est osée manifester
en Chine ça disait quelque chose d'un
ras-le-bol plus large plus vaste que les
mesures sanitaires dont nous avons voulu
comprendre les causes
alors on va découvrir tout de suite ce
reportage Chine génération confinée un
sujet de lookiziela Antoine Morel et
Yann Chan
[Musique]
G
les cris de colère d'une jeunesse
chinoise à bout de nerfs
contre la stratégie zéro covid et même
contre le pouvoir communiste
[Musique]
fin novembre 2022 ces slogans résonnent
à Shanghai Pékin et par tout ailleurs
dans le pays du jamais vu depuis le
mouvement étudiant de 1989
[Applaudissements]
oser ainsi défiez les autorités
chinoises paraissaient impensable
un mouvement spontané sans meneur
[Musique]
en moins de trois jours l'appareil
sécuritaire étouffe la contestation
une semaine plus tard Pékin démentel sa
politique zéroville
[Musique]
mais les racines du malaise sont le plus
profondes dans un pays où la censure
règne en mètre ou toute critique et
sévèrement réprimée pourquoi ces
milliers de jeunes se sont-ils révoltés
quelles sont les causes de cette colère
de cet afro à l'autorité de Sidi in pink
[Musique]
après les manifestations les
arrestations se multiplient alors les
témoignages sont très rares ce
shanghaïen lui veut raconter ce qu'il
s'est passé pour sa sécurité vous ne
verrez pas son visage
cette manifestation était pacifique il
n'y a pas eu de débordement de notre
côté mais dès que vous alliez sur place
vous étiez arrêté tout de suite la
police emmenait les gens de manière très
brutale nous avons tous ressenti la même
peur à ce moment-là
cette nuit là il échappe aux
interpellations mais l'un de ses amis
passe de nuit en prison cette répression
éclaire du mouvement le décourage
il sera très difficile de former un
nouveau une telle résistance ailleurs
dans le monde c'est normal d'exprimer
ses revendications mais dans notre pays
on ne peut exprimer aucune opposition
aucun débat n'est possible donc
intérieurement je me sens très
impuissant mais je veux quand même
lutter un peu
si le jeune homme ose de telles
critiques c'est qu'il est excédé et
traumatisé par le confinement de
Shanghai pendant plus de deux mois au
printemps dernier alors privé de revenus
il a dormi dehors pendant des semaines
et je n'ai pas pu le payer pendant trop
longtemps alors ils m'ont mis à la porte
à l'extérieur j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
que les gens confinés n'imaginent même
pas
de nombreuses personnes dormaient sur le
trottoir et j'entendais des gens crier
j'entendais déjà en dire qu'il voulait
mourir
les confinements stricts marquent toute
une génération à l'âge de l'indépendance
des centaines de millions de jeunes
Chinois ont dû supporter l'enfermement
les universités sont alors des
forteresses sanitaires sous la politique
zéro covid elles sont coupées du monde
à Shanghai de mars à juin 2022 les
élèves ont même interdiction de quitter
leur dortoir
une étudiante dont nous protégeons
l'identité nous fait visiter la chambre
où elle a été confinée
[Musique]
voici notre dortoir nous sommes quatre à
vivre ici
il y a le lit en haut des rangements en
bas pour les vêtements les chaussures
et là à gauche du lit le bureau pour
étudier
quatre filles dans 20 mètres carrés
pendant 3 mois elle suit les courants
lignes depuis son bureau même les repas
sont livrés dans la chambre seule ces
rideaux sur le lit lui offre un semblant
d'intimité
sur cette chaise tous les jours face à
ce mur et à ce bureau je trouvais la vie
très monotone et ennuyeuse
bien sûr il y a eu des moments où on
n'arrivait pas à se motiver pour étudier
et travailler on avait l'impression de
n'avoir rien à espérer ni attendre de la
vie
une période difficile pour la jeune
femme et pour ses pères d'après un
sondage mené par des psychologues plus
de 80% des étudiants à Shanghai
souffrent de dépression et d'anxiété
je souffrais énormément de la solitude
je ressentais aussi la détresse des
autres étudiants
tout ce qu'on nous disait c'était
d'endurer
pour tenir psychologiquement nous étions
comme livrés à nous-mêmes
[Musique]
critiquer ces mesures sanitaires les
exposent à des sanctions alors les
étudiants confinés sur les campus trouve
d'autres moyens de relâcher la pression
dans plusieurs universités ces images
deviennent virales on y voit des élèves
tourner en rond à quatre pattes d'autres
promènent des animaux en carton
une mode mais aussi une manière
détournée de dénoncer l'absurdité de
leur situation
avec la levée des restrictions les
campus ouvre à nouveau l'étudiante peut
maintenant réviser à l'extérieur mais la
plupart des cours et des examens sont
toujours en ligne elle reste marquée par
le confinement
on installe nous devons garder cette
colère face à l'injustice et aux
politiques déraisonnable qui nous ont
été imposés sinon on aura aucune chance
de changer les choses
cette envie de changement c'est celle
d'une partie de la jeunesse de la classe
moyenne
urbaine et diplômée la fronde reste donc
minoritaire mais elle inquiète un parti
obnubilé par la stabilité sociale
pour son allocution du Nouvel An sidine
ping finit son discours en s'adressant
directement aux jeunes comme une mise en
garde
les jeunes Chinois doivent cultiver leur
dévouement à la patrie et rechercher le
progrès pour faire rayonner leur
jeunesse et être à la hauteur de notre
époque
sauf que le rêve chinois a du plomb dans
l'aile avec seulement 3% en 2022 la
croissance est au plus bas depuis des
décennies
[Musique]
l'économie ralentit est prêt d'un jeune
chinois sur 6 est au chômage dans les
grandes villes du jamais vu après des
années de développement fulgurant même
les grandes entreprises de la tech
licencie aujourd'hui en masse
ciao bye vient d'être remercié par
l'équivalent chinois de YouTube et ce
n'est pas son premier licenciement
j'ai eu trois emplois au cours des
quatre dernières années pour le premier
j'étais licencié au bout de deux ans et
après environ un an pour les deux autres
son salaire elle ne peut plus payer de
loyer à Shanghai elle vient donc de
rentrer chez ses parents à 28 ans
startup ou géant d'Internet tous ces
anciens employeurs souffrent de la crise
sanitaire et de régulation drastique
imposée par le gouvernement 2021
déjà très compétitif le secteur de la
tech est devenu invivable selon elle
j'arrivais au bureau à 10h du matin
et je ne quittais pas mon poste avant
21h ou 22h
la compétition était féroce on
travaillait tous très tard pour montrer
au patron qu'on était productif pour
garder notre travail
tout le monde était très angoissé
de retour au domicile familial dans une
petite ville la jeune femme fille unique
subit la pression sociale
ma famille espère toujours que je trouve
un emploi stable
car ce qui leur importe le plus c'est
que quand il me présente à leur
entourage il puisse dire que j'ai un
véritable emploi alors qu'un freelance
pour eux c'est comme un parasite
ça fait mauvaise impression
pour d'autres jeunes l'avenir ne s'écrit
plus en Chine
sur Internet les recherches sur
l'immigration explosent mais le sujet
est sensible pour contourner la censure
l'envie de partir a donc un surnom run
comme le mot anglais courir
le caractère run signifie l'humidité
mais comme en lettres latine il s'écrit
comme le mot anglais run
c'est très pratique pour se référer à
l'émigration et pour parler de l'envie
de partir
Sarah veut s'installer au Canada avec
son petit ami pour préparer leur départ
elle se donne un an maximum
avant le confinement de Shanghai j'avais
déjà pensé à partir mais je n'avais pas
encore cette détermination
comme dans le passé j'ai étudié et vécu
à l'étranger je sais à quoi ressemble
une vie et une organisation sociale
normale dans le reste du monde ici j'ai
l'impression que l'environnement général
est comme un bateau qui est sur le point
de poulet
quitter la Chine Shanghai et ses proches
restent un crève-cœur
ses parents sont d'anciens
fonctionnaires des fidèles du parti avec
eux le dialogue est presque impossible
comme mes parents sont très
conservateurs et traditionnels dans leur
façon de penser ils ont beaucoup de
préjugés contre les pays étrangers
mais je peux pas expliquer en détail mes
raisons parce que selon eux aucun pays
dans le monde n'est aussi bien ni aussi
sûr que la Chine
sa décision est irrévocable son futur
elle ne l'imagine pas en Chine
je ne peux pas être prisonnière de mes
parents toute ma vie
je ne veux pas que mon enfant naisse et
grandissant Chine je pense que ça vaut
la peine de partir pour le bien de la
prochaine génération et pour avoir un
meilleur environnement pour vivre
depuis la fin de la politique zéro covid
certains jeunes Chinois aspirent à
reprendre une vie normale dans leur pays
mais pour Sarah et pour beaucoup
d'autres il est déjà trop tard
[Musique]
toujours à Shanghai en duplex loup qui
s'y est là lou comment est-ce que Pékin
fait face à cette contestation
sans surprise les images des
manifestations ont très vite été
censurées et sur les lieux des
rassemblements notamment ici à Shanghai
il y a eu un déploiement policier massif
pendant plusieurs semaines pour
dissuader toute tentative de recommencer
on l'a entendu dans le reportage
plusieurs manifestants ont été arrêtés
sur place et aujourd'hui encore la
police chinoise continue les
interrogatoires voir les arrestations de
personnes repérées dans ces
rassemblements ont c'est très difficile
de savoir exactement combien mais on
sait que quatre jeunes femmes ont été
arrêtées fin décembre l'une d'entre
elles a enregistré une vidéo avant
d'être emmenée par la police elle
s'appelle Sao jessing elle a 26 ans elle
est éditrice je vous propose de
l'écouter
si vous voyez cette vidéo c'est que la
police m'a emmenée comme d'autres amis
avant moi ils ont dû signer leur mandat
d'arrêt mais le document ne dit pas quel
est le chef d'accusation la police
refuse de dire combien de temps ils
seront détenus ou et pourquoi
a priori depuis cette vidéo l'entourage
de ces jeunes femmes n'a pas reçu plus
d'informations sur leurs conditions de
détention alors nous on sait que les
conditions de tournage sont compliquées
en Chine d'une manière générale qu'elles
ont été vos difficultés pour ce
reportage précisément
d'une manière générale en tant que
journaliste étranger c'est très
difficile de recueillir des témoignages
ici encore plus devant une caméra et
même pour des sujets qui ne sont pas
sensibles ça arrive très souvent que des
interlocuteurs potentiels refusent de
nous parler de peur que le simple fait
de donner une interview à un média
étranger ne leur porte préjudice donc
pour ce reportage nous avons contacté
beaucoup de jeunes Chinois qui auraient
voulu s'exprimer qui aurait aimé
raconter leurs histoires mais qui
finalement ont décliné de peur que ça
ait des conséquences et donc pour la
sécurité de nos interlocuteurs nous
avons pris beaucoup de précautions pour
les contacter pour discuter avec eux et
pour enregistrer leur témoignage c'est
aussi pour ça que la plupart d'entre eux
sont anonymes dans ce reportage
à Shanghai pour France 24 merci lou
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter
[Musique]